The narrative
for the presidential campaign
flipped on Friday
after the president's
positive COVID test.
Now the Trump campaign
has shifted to virtual events,
while Joe Biden hits the trail.
Joining us now from Minneapolis,
Senator Amy Klobuchar,
a key backer of the former vice
president.
Senator, what are your thoughts
about the president's illness?
First of all, the fact
that the president
and first lady have contracted
COVID.
And secondly, how he's handled
COVID over these last months.
Well first, Chris, my prayers
are with the president
and the first lady,
and all of their staff,
and the Republican senators
that we are we now know are ill.
And we wish them all
a speedy recovery.
I think it was Joe Biden that
said that this should be not
about partisanship, not
about politics,
this is an American moment.
And to me that means electing
a president that has a plan
instead of pandemonium.
I think it means putting
a strong leader in place that,
number one,
understands we listen
to the experts.
Just like the doctor you just
had on who was telling people
yes, wear masks
in public settings.
By the way it'll save 100,000
lives in 100 days.
You need a plan for having
a national testing strategy,
which would help us immensely
with our economy
so businesses can reopen
in a very consistent way.
And then the third thing
is transparency with contact
tracing and the like.
And we just haven't seen that.
We've heard things like oh, this
will be done by Easter.
Oh, this will go away
with warm weather.
Oh, this is a hoax.
This is deeply personal to me,
Chris.
You know that.
My husband was very, very sick.
Had pneumonia.
Was in the hospital for nearly
a week.
And it is deeply personal to so
many Americans, it is now
personal to the president.
But it is deeply personal to so
many people.
And that's why I think you see
in states like Florida
now since the debate, where
people didn't like what they
heard from the president.
Joe Biden is up five points
in a poll yesterday.
Or he's up in Pennsylvania.
Clearly Democrats, Republicans,
and Independents want someone
that is following the facts,
and is going to help them out
and their families,
and get us
through this pandemic.
Senator, the Biden campaign
has taken down all
of its negative ads.
But the president--
some Republicans
are saying that Democrats are
still attacking the president
while he's now in the hospital.
Should discussions about COVID
be
off-limits at this particular
point?
Well, not discussions
about COVID.
Not when you had seven million
people get this virus.
Not when you have people in
assisted living who have been
isolated for this entire year.
And moms juggling their kids
on their laps
while they're trying to do
their work.
Uh, no.
But I think Joe Biden has set
the tone here, because he's
a leader.
And he said, look.
I want the president to be back.
He wants to debate him more.
He wants him to have
a speedy recovery.
And so this isn't about politics
or partisanship.
But certainly the pandemic,
the effect that it's had
on people's lives,
how they have miscalculated
at this administration,
of course that's on the table.
Because as Joe pointed out
at the debate, we have 200,000
families right now that have
a chair at the table that's
empty.
So it is on the table.
As well as the economy,
and how we can get
through the day after tomorrow.
And the kind of leadership
you'll need to make sure we get
there.
Right.
The issue of how to campaign
during a pandemic
came up during Tuesday's debate.
Take a look, Senator.
And I'll have 25,000, 35,000
people show up at airports.
We use airports and--
Are you not--
--hangars, and--
--worried about the disease--
--we have a lot of people--
--issues sir?
Well so far,
we have had no problem
whatsoever.
It's outside.
He's been totally
irresponsible the way in which
he has handled
the social distancing and people
wearing a mask.
Basically, encouraged them not
to.
This raises the whole question
of how to reopen the country.
Whether it's reopening
and how you conduct
the campaign.
Whether it's reopening
the economy.
Whether it's reopening schools.
You just heard Trump campaign
advisor, Steve Cortes, say---
and the president said
in the debate--
that Joe Biden is being too
cautious.
Too much of an alarmist.
And is too ready to shut down
the government again.
Or rather, shut down the economy
again.
Excuse me.
Joe Biden has made it really
clear that he wants to build
back better.
And he wants to get this economy
to a place where we're actually
expanding.
And, in fact, I'd
note that Moody's, not exactly
a liberal organization,
just said that Joe Biden's plan
will add 7 million
more jobs next year than Donald
Trump's plan.
And so he wants to do that.
But he believes you use science
as a guide, that's all.
And you can see you shouldn't
just have testing for White
House staff.
We should be able to have
grocery store clerks,
and nurses,
and first responders.
They should be able to have more
frequent testing, too.
And there is a way to do this.
But right now, it's just
this idea that, oh, this is
going to get better.
We've turned the corner,
as your first guest just said.
Thirty-three states, that's
the facts.
The doctor said them.
Thirty-three states we've seen
increases right now
in the last few weeks.
And so what that [AUDIO OUT]
into me?
We can get through this.
There's so much promising work
being done on vaccines,
but to get to that point
we have to have
a national testing strategy.
And then we also have to have
an economic plan for what I call
the day after tomorrow.
So we can get
through this stronger.
Senator, it turns out that two
of your Republican colleagues
on the Senate Judiciary
Committee, Senators Mike Lee
and Thom Tillis,
have now tested positive
for COVID.
Are Democrats going to try
to use this as a way to delay
the confirmation hearing,
and the confirmation vote
on Judge Barrett?
It's not a matter of using it,
Chris.
It happened.
And the first thing we know
is that if you look
at the precedent
that Mitch McConnell set,
we should let the people decide.
And that's where the majority
of people
are when it comes to this.
Decide who the president is
after this election,
and let them pick the nominee.
Secondly, we've got the fact
that now three senators have it.
As you point out,
two are on the Judiciary
Committee.
And Mitch McConnell has shut
the Senate down for two
[AUDIO OUT]
because of health concerns.
Because we don't know how many
other Republican senators
had it.
There were a number
of other ones
that were at the Rose Garden.
They have a lunch together where
they don't have masks.
We don't do that
on the Democratic side.
They do.
And so it's very possible
we're going to have more
senators, more staff.
So I don't know why you would
ram through the Supreme Court
hearing, put people in danger,
because it would be
within that two-week period,
while you have shut down
the whole Senate.
I just think it's wrong.
We are suggesting that they
wait.
But Senator, the fact
is that you can hold hearings
in different ways.
In fact, last May, when
the chairman of the Judiciary
Committee, Lindsey Graham,
held a virtual hearing,
you very much praised him,
and thanked him for doing that.
So you could hold
a virtual hearing for Judge
Barrett.
Which raises the question again,
are you trying to use the fact
that there has been
this outbreak, at least
three Republican senators,
to try to block a nomination
that you frankly oppose
fiercely?
Absolutely not.
This is for the highest court
of the land.
And yes, we have had
virtual hearings.
I helped to put them together.
It's important to give senators
that option.
But you want to be able to go
back and forth
with this nominee.
Given her views
on the Affordable Care Act,
given that she has clearly
criticized Justice Roberts, who
again,
not exactly a blazing liberal,
for upholding the constitutional
of the Affordable Care Act,
which allows people to keep
their insurance when they've got
preexisting conditions.
And she has criticized that?
Yeah, we want to able
to ask her--
Yeah, but we're doing it.
We're doing this virtually,
Senator.
so why can't you question Judge
Barrett virtually?
Again, we believe you should
have an in-person hearing.
That doesn't mean
the virtual option wouldn't be
available.
But why would you ram--
I guess I turned the question
around here, even though you get
to ask the questions.
Why would you ram this
through when we don't even have
a COVID package done to make
sure that people have health
care?
That we have the testing
I just talked about.
That we have the funding
for that.
The Senate Republicans have been
resisting this, while Nancy
Pelosi has been valiantly
working on it, and the White
House now claims they want
a package.
Why would be doing this
instead of actually be helping
the American people?
So that's why I think it is so
important that that's what we
do,
instead of ramming
through a Supreme Court justice.
Wait until after the election.
Better for safety.
Better for the country.
Senator Klobuchar, thank you.
Thanks for your time
this weekend.
Please come back.
I will, and I did that all
without interrupting you once,
I would like to point out, Chris
Wallace.
I interrupted you a couple
of times.
It's a little hard on this Skype
deal.
Senator, thank you.